Bandwidth and latency are the two
networky things that people often mean
when they refer to speed
of a network connection.
Or rather, low bandwidth and high
latency can both feel like slowness.
This is a map of the world.
Well actually, it's just a map
of the Northern hemisphere.
But that's okay.
It'll do for this example.
Here are a few places around the world.
Here's Alice.
Alice lives in California.
Alice clicks a button in your web app.
The app performs a query
to your web server.
But Alice is here.
And your web server's over here
in Riga Latvia, many hops away.
Maybe traffic has to go to Chicago,
to New York,
over the ocean to London,
down into France,
bum around in like the middle of Europe
for a while, eventually get to Latvia.
And then your server itself consults
an API server that's
back in let's say Paris.
And that takes some time to respond.
By the time the response gets
all the way back to Alice,
it's been a few seconds.
So the app's response to Alice's mouse
click doesn't feel instantaneous.
It feels laggy.
That's high latency.
Now here's Bob.
Bob's computer is from 1997, and
he's using an old dial up
modem to connect to his ISP.
Bob goes to your website.
And his browser starts downloading
your site's logo which is 100
kilobytes in size.
Over the next 15 seconds, your logo
slowly appears on Bob's screen.
That's low bandwidth.
Now one of the biggest contributors to
latency on the network is just plain
old distance and number of hops.
Internet signals are bound
by the speed of light.
And the routers that move
them around the globe
take some time to switch
their signals around.
When you're done with this video,
I suggest you go watch
Admiral Grace Hopper's video entitled
Nanoseconds, which is on YouTube, to get
an idea of just how far things can
travel in those short periods of time.
Now depending on what your app does and
how your users use it,
bandwidth may not matter much at all.
If you're serving big photos or
video, of course it will.
If you're serving mostly text and small
images, your site can be fast even for
people on very low bandwidth networks.
Today that's less likely to mean old
modems, and more likely to mean maybe
slow cell phones, which are actually
not all that much faster than dial up.